Good morning John and Hank, it's Friday.
My name is Rosianna. I'm John's producing
partner, John and Hanks's secret sister, a youtuber
over at youtube.com/Rosianna and an
avid user of the internet. That being
said, today's video is about logging off.
Not too long ago, I hit my limit of the
social internet, I scrambled my passwords,
I deleted apps from my phone, I backed
quickly away and promptly read more
books in a week than I'd read in the
previous two months. I found that I was
less anxious, less angry and I
communicated far better with friends
about how I was actually doing. I'm not here
to say, though, that the internet is bad. For one,
I live thousands of kilometers away from
most of my friends so I love seeing
updates from Nando's or from the central
line. For two, I don't think the Internet
is intrinsically anything. It's a tool
and system we use, and I read a piece in
Offscreen magazine recently that kind
of summed this up for me.
We think the Internet is inherently a
certain way but it isn't. It's constantly
changing, and we are the ones who are
changing it.
We can change it for the better, rather
than having to change ourselves to adapt
the parts that are toxic for us.
The internet seems like it's made up of code
and clouds, but really it's made up of
people. Like so much, it comes back to
community. Prior to my mini internet
break, part my reluctance to step back
is that I've defined myself through the internet.
I've defended the internet to other people.
I've defended the joy of meeting
strangers and the special thrill of
making something with people you will
never meet. Whether that's something
deeply useful, deeply silly, or something
that fall somewhere between the two that
may bring a smile, but won't necessarily
feed the world. A friend of mine
suggested to me that maybe the murkiness
of the internet, that led to me taking a
break, and is infused to all of these
discussions of online discourse, is that
it wasn't really designed to hold so
many people. Maybe when I used to
log on to AOL, always after 6pm and
only if my sisters weren't on the phone,
there were fewer people online and that's what
made it fun.
We were working it out together and building
it together, rather than entering an internet
which felt as ready-made as Ikea
furniture. With experts and prose and
rights and wrongs, and yes, the occasional
missing bolt. I struggle to believe that,
though, I think we're still building the
internet, there are still voices we aren't
hearing, there is still work to do.
It reminds me of one of my favourite scenes
from The West Wing, when a character called
Jeff asked Josh to take out a dollar
bill, turn it over and look at the
incomplete pyramid. He says the seal
is meant to be unfinished because this
country's meant to be unfinished. We're
meant to keep doing better. Yes, it's
idealistic, but I
genuinely believe that. The internet is
not an iron bunker, buried deep deep deep deep
underground, it's infrastructure. And as
humans change, and we learn more about
what helps us and helps other people,
the internet will change, and we will
change it. We will have more and better
ideas about what to do next,
not what to do last. Having said all of
that with such confidence, I think we are
at a time of the internet when a lot of people
claim to know the right answer. And the
idea of the mass of humanity can be
broken down into bullet point lists or
alphas and betas is to me contradictory
to everything that humans have
demonstrated over time. Maybe we start by
not knowing, and what was helpful to me in my
time stepping back from the internet was
realizing how bloody long it had been
since I had clicked logout or log off;
since I had made an intentional and
active decision about my online behaviour,
rather than a passive one. It clicked though
when I open my computer, I'm often
on automatic: my twitter feed, my inbox, my calendar.
I'm kind of in a nothing state, and
in that nothing state, I am plasticine,
and who am I handing that plasticine to?
Just to get fully quote-tastic here, in a
Lenny Letter, Zadie Smith recently
wrote: "The feels have to possess a
certain amount of vertical depth. It's
like lowering a stone down into the well
of yourself, and the further it goes the
deeper it resounds. A lot of the social
platforms provoke feelings in me I
simply don't enjoy. For a moment, I am
flattered, falsely puffed up, briefly
amused, painfully hurt or infuriated."
John, you recommended to me the brilliant
podcast 'Invisibilia', and on that there
was an episode about how, in Rwanda,
legislation had been passed to require
equal representation in government. But
that episode was also about how that
legislation didn't necessarily affect or
improve gender inequality around the
country. Essentially, and I'll put the full
episode in the description bar below because
it's great, that shortcut didn't quite
work and it may be wonder whether
Twitter was a shortcut that didn't quite
work, whether we needed to do more long
hard work to get to some of the benefits
and include some of the benefits that
website like Twitter provide: hearing from
more voices, community organizing. Because
otherwise we maybe have a bit of a
tendency to feel stuck or feel like
those are the ultimate solutions.
The long hard work maybe doesn't let us
pretend to rest easy and admire the
pyramid and see it as complete. The truth
is I don't know, and I'm curious to hear
your thoughts.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.